doctors are notoriously bad patients and
I fall into that category headstrong and
recently I went for my checkup and found
out something really bad about my health
and I want to share that with you huge
thanks to Walmart Plus for sponsoring
this video
I've been kind of slacking on my health
over the last year and a half I'd like
to blame the pandemic and that's
certainly been a part of it but a lot of
it has also come from the fact that I've
been a little bit lazy and I've been
slacking and that's okay but when push
comes to shove we have to take care of
our health but I knew for me it was time
to get a checkup get my blood work done
figure out what my risk factors were and
this is a really important teaching
Point here because you don't need to get
blood work done all the time it's about
knowing the right intervals of when to
get your blood checked that's why it's
so important to have a family medicine
doctor to guide you on when you should
be getting your cholesterol checked when
you should get your sugar checked blood
work has to be ordered with a purpose
because we treat the patient not the lab
value in fact when you get blood work
done too often that increases the rate
of medical error because something could
be off just in that given moment and it
really confuses and muddles the picture
not to mention the health care spending
that comes with that for me one of the
tests I needed to order especially
knowing how poor my diet has been over
the last year I needed to check my
cholesterol I didn't expect this at all
um my cholesterol is through the roof in
fact it was getting to be at such a high
level that it was almost falling into
the category of you can't get it this
high with just the diet we need to check
if you have a familial Gene for
hypercholesterolemia if I had a patient
my age walk in with that cholesterol I
would have a very serious conversation
about genetic testing my number my LDL
cholesterol was 185 getting into the
190s is like potentially have a heart
attack at age 40 with no symptoms bad
and I don't want to have a heart attack
I don't want to die it was a brutal
wake-up call for me the general goal is
we want to get the LDL cholesterol below
100. so in going back to see what I was
doing I realized I developed some really
bad habits and their bad habits that I
want to highlight with you today because
it goes to argue the point that weight
is not the single determinant of your
health status I was not eating a lot of
calories during the day therefore my
weight was okay but my cholesterol
markers were terrible because of the
type of foods I was consuming here's how
a typical day went I would wake up not
eat anything I'm a big fan of
intermittent fasting don't have much of
an appetite in the morning so then I
would continue along with my day till
lunchtime where I would have a salad and
then came dinner time I was still
working because I work really late hours
where it would be like 10 11 12 a.m and
I'm done with work but I'm starving and
I worked out in the morning so I burned
like 800 calories I need to consume some
serious calories right now in order to
not lose weight and keep some muscle on
so what I ended up doing was binge
eating late at night really low quality
foods an extra cheese pizza with
pepperoni on it I would take you to the
face a cheeseburger a double
cheeseburger nuggets or some kind of
like crispy sure so for the day I only
consume like 22 2300 calories burned 800
in the morning I was good my body was
looking great like my six-pack would
start even coming in but my cholesterol
levels were quietly going through the
roof because I was consuming a lot of
saturated fat a lot of fried foods
unhealthy Foods a lot of red meat giant
steak like it was way too much red meat
because I need someone to be objective I
reached out to my good friend Dr
Danielle belardo who's a well-trained
cardiologist knows everything about
cholesterol and low wearing cholesterol
and I knew she could be of help LDL
cholesterol is the actual most important
cholesterol that we look at with regards
to cardiac risk even though I think you
may have possibly some genetic
components of high cholesterol I do
think that there's a lot you can do to
reduce your LDL with diet significantly
Dr belardo gave me three tips on how to
lower my LDL cholesterol from least to
most important that I follow third is to
decrease dietary cholesterol reducing
the amount of any sort of kind of
processed foods junk Foods refined
carbohydrates that can make a huge
difference second is to bump up my fiber
intake to about 60 grams of fiber per
day not an easy task fiber only exists
in plants and so by eating more
plant-based Foods whether it be fruits
vegetables whole grains legumes this can
help reduce your cholesterol as well and
your LDL specifically and first and most
important is to decrease my saturated
fat consumption saturate fat we can see
in both animal products and plant
products for example coconut oil is
really high in saturated fat can raise
your LDL so dropping a saturated fat by
cutting back on red meat butter bacon
cheese or high fat Dairy that can make a
huge difference too knowing my
cholesterol was so high I knew I needed
to start eating healthier but eating
healthy isn't always so simple but it
has become easier because of my Walmart
Plus Membership you see a membership
gives you free same-day delivery of
fresh groceries from your local store
they've got high quality ingredients for
your everyday cooking like organic
fruits or vegetables or boneless
skinless chicken breasts with a Walmart
plus membership prices are the same as
they are on the Shelf so there are no
markups which means you get the same
fresh high quality food you've come to
expect from Walmart at reasonable prices
and because of these low prices the
Walmart plus membership is perfect from
everything from weekly meal planning to
Preparing seasonal dishes or just
filling in the gaps when you've
unexpectedly run out of something and
believe me this election is excellent
offering fresh fruit like these avocados
which can lower your LDL or plums that
have a lot of fiber in them something I
need a lot of right now and once you
place an order specially trained
Shoppers hand pick the freshest items
just like they're shopping for their own
families organic fruits and vegetables
like these tomatoes are pick the Dave
the delivery not the day before so you
can really see and taste the difference
and they don't just deliver fresh food
products though they also deliver a lot
of what you need for your home your
family like paper towels beauty products
and even my most loved sparkling water I
just need those bubbles click the link
below to start your free trial now I was
primarily now getting my protein sources
from fish as the number one source
plants like beans and then chicken those
are like my three primary sources of
protein when it comes to the second
point of increasing fiber that was
probably the hardest Not only was my GI
system kind of a mess like I was bloated
having some flatulence issues once my
body adjusted to the huge jump in fiber
content I started feeling a lot better
and I became more regular and all of
that improved but how did I get there
first I started having to take a fiber
supplement the reality though is even
when you take a fiber supplement twice a
day you're only increasing your fiber
intake by like five or six grams so I
still had to find other ways to get my
fiber in the best way that I found to
get my fibrin was through black beans
and I like Black beans I think they
taste great they have some protein and
the fiber content is amazing there's
ways you can pick Bean foods that aren't
actually beans there's ways to make your
pasta to be legume based you drastically
increase the amount of fiber you're
consuming I also found some Fiber to go
bars protein bar that had some fiber in
them that was also plant-based I got
some freeze-dried blueberries and
raspberries which have a great amount of
fiber in them over the next month
because it's been about a month now
following this I will say certain
changes became visible quickly first I
actually lost 10 to like 12 pounds I
wasn't intending to lose the weight but
I was and I was starting to look and
feel better I feel more energized when I
wake up in the mornings my stomach isn't
as bloated I don't feel as full like
nasty full throughout the day but it's
also made a big difference in how I
perform in everyday tasks in life but
the benefit that I'm doing for my health
by eating this way is huge the
raspberries and blueberries I'm eating
don't just have fiber they have vitamins
and minerals in them the beans that I'm
consuming are good for my heart there's
so much other added value in eating this
way that goes just past the cholesterol
Point like it really woke me up to the
mistakes that I was making in my dietary
habits and this goes to show two things
one that just because you're a doctor
you're an expert in something doesn't
mean you're always making the right
choices for yourselves doctors are
probably the biggest Hypocrites and
second that despite being a a healthy
weight and having nearly a six-pack I
was unhealthy our health goes past our
weight
all right it's been a couple of days I
got my test results back I needed to see
that my total cholesterol would go down
and by changing my lifestyle I know that
if my total cholesterol goes down it's
because the LDL went down which is the
bad cholesterol and it worked my total
cholesterol number totally went out and
it went down significantly in just five
short weeks initially my total
cholesterol 265. now 217. if I check
this three months later it'd probably be
even below 200 which is ideally where we
want it to be so now I have to keep my
cholesterol low and healthy by
continuing this lifestyle that doesn't
mean I won't occasionally indulge in
some pizza or burgers or like chicken
nuggets or something but I've learned to
love fiber rich foods I've learned to
incorporate more plant-based Foods in my
diet and frankly I feel like my palette
has evolved it's like a Pokemon now you
know my cholesterol score but do you
know my sister click here for a special
video about us huge thanks to Walmart
Plus for sponsoring this video don't
forget to click that link in description
and start your free trial now as always
stay happy and healthy
[Music]